this has to be one of one of the most
phenomenal
astronomical
events that you can see with your naked
eye i mean i'm just looking at the sun
right now oh it got a little bit
brighter around the edge
well we're here at the university of
nottingham in nottingham but we're
getting ready to jump on a couple planes
to go to china so that we can still be
at the university of nottingham
well there happens to be a total solar
eclipse that's happening
in just
a little over a day
and it passes the path of totality
passes right over the university of
nottingham in ningbo china
at the moment it looks like it's going
to be cloudy so i'm really really hoping
that the clouds
are not with us
um
the forecast looks very grim it seems
that there's a front moving in tomorrow
morning
it doesn't look good
so here we are in
china at the university of nottingham
ningbo campus we finally arrived and so
we're anticipating this big solar
eclipse tomorrow while we're watching
occasional
lightning bolts quite on cue right there
they just cover the entire half of the
sky in the direction where the sun is
actually supposed to rise tomorrow
morning where we're going to see this
this fantastic astronomical event maybe
so i'm still keeping my hopes up but i'm
not positive that we're actually going
to be able to see it
we've been traveling for
two days two and a half i forget what
day it is at the moment but i know that
tomorrow morning at 9 37 a.m local time
is when the big event happens
well it's 4 54 a.m
and we just came out to see what the sky
looks like
and to see what the potential is for the
the solar eclipse this morning and it
doesn't
look very good
not very promising indeed
beautiful but not good for sun for a
solar event
we went out for the sunrise this morning
and the weather did not look terribly
fantastic but after a little break and a
cup of tea we came back out again to see
the clouds not quite so thick and we can
actually see the sun up there so what i
have right here is
my
very own solar filter that i made this
is a roll of black and white film it has
to be actually black and white not the
color film that they just developed
black and white but real black and white
film so you expose it to the sun and
then you send it off to be developed and
then it has this nice layer of silver on
there that acts as a filter for the the
ultraviolet and the infrared that's the
most damage most harmful for your eyes
but we have a good chance of actually
getting the solar eclipse okay now i'm
really excited
yeah in
in 10
maybe
10 minutes
10 minutes it'll cover
so we've just reached the first contact
point and that's when the edge of the
moon first touches the edge of the sun
so it's now just starting to pass in
front of it we have about an hour now
until the the total eclipse phase starts
so it's the sun moon and earth in a
straight line the moon actually covers
the sun well it might seem slow it takes
the moon a while to cover the sun
completely but actually the shadow of of
the moon is barreling across the surface
of the earth at about 2 000 miles per
hour i'm fascinated by the idea of what
ancient people thought when the sun just
completely went away there are different
stories about how they reacted the
ancient chinese in fact thought that
dragons were attacking the sun and they
were going to eat it and take it away so
what they decided to do was just make
noise beat drums scream make as much
noise as they could to get rid of the
moon and to keep the sun and so luckily
every time that actually happened and
they got the sun back
well people have just decided to gather
to watch they've been using some of our
solar eclipse glasses and the kids are
are playing with feathers they don't
really know what's going on
they think the sun looks like the
crescent moon or they keep saying i see
the crescent moon
because
the moon's actually covering the sun
so normally when the the sun goes down
the animals start to go back to their
burrows and go to sleep and so right now
they start to they look like they are
the birds are kind of going away they're
small little floaty things that are
leaving and the the ducks just started
to go hide in the trees but a couple of
kids went and yelled at them so they
didn't really know what to do
that's fantastic
oh my gosh
oh my gosh this has to be one of the
coolest things i've ever seen you can
see
the corona glowing around the sun and
the temperature just dropped completely
and everyone started cheering and
i completely didn't think we were going
to be able to see it like that
fireworks are going off
you could see a little bit of red at the
very edge where the
where we could see the last bit of light
it's amazingly dark when i look through
my binoculars i can actually see um
some of the the outer ring some of the
corona sort of flickering and i don't
think that's entirely due to the clouds
i actually think that has something to
do with
with the light coming out
i mean can you um could you imagine even
thousands of years ago seeing something
like this and having any idea what was
going on
you can hear people yelling in the
distance and screaming and cheering
oh my gosh
if we could actually see
if there weren't any clouds oh we can
there's venus
hey there's venus
so we can see the planet venus right
there really bright
and if we could see the clouds around
the sun we'd be able to see mercury
yeah this is amazing this is amazing the
clouds are coming in a little bit more
now so you can't see it quite as well
but
how does this rain on your astronomy
experiences i mean even with the clouds
this has to be one of one of the most
phenomenal
astronomical
events that you can see with your naked
eye i mean i'm just looking at the sun
right now oh it got a little bit
brighter around the edge
oh and it just doesn't happen very often
in
each spot
on the earth
oh my gosh
it just popped back out
that was a quick four minutes i have to
tell you
so the sun just popped back out on the
other side of the moon so it's brighter
again instantly so i'm wrapping a foil
around our camera so we can actually
look at it again and now i have to use
these
the next total solar eclipse will be in
about one year from now it's july 11th
2010 and it will go past it will go over
easter island and chile and some of
argentina so i have to figure out a good
reason to go down there
so university of nottingham campus
easter island maybe
we're just sitting here glowing with the
enjoyment of what we just saw it's
amazing that four and a half minutes
went so quickly
wow